in this video i'm going to show you how
to make beautiful
presentation worthy tables using the
knitter and cable extra packages in r
now before you watch this tutorial
though i do strongly recommend that you
watch my r
markdown tutorial that's where i walk
you through
starting from an rmd script in r where
you've got
your code your header your commentary
and your output all in one location
how you can transform that into a
presentation-worthy document that's in
a word document an html or a pdf
format well i mentioned at the end of
that tutorial that creating good-looking
tables
is a subject for its own tutorial and
that's what i'm gonna cover for you here
today
so if this is your first time here my
name is richard this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already and smash the like
button for the youtube algorithm
now without further ado let's get
started starting out with our packages
i'm going to start by calling the tidy
verse i do that every time just out of
habit
then our two key packages today are
going to be knitter
and cable extra but you are also going
to need this tiny text package for
certain additional functionality
so specifically if you want to knit an
rmd
file to turn that into a pdf document
you are going to need a local
installation of latex
and you're also going to need this tiny
text package
tiny text tinytac however you want to
pronounce that
then there's certain additional latex
formatting options that you can do with
your tables directly in your document
if you want those latex formatting
options again you need latex installed
and you need this tiny text package
we're going to demo all of our uh cable
extra
and knitter uh tables in this document
on the credit card data set
and the credit card data set comes from
the aer package
so then additionally i'm gonna provide
you some links to some additional
tutorials
uh you have a tutorial on knitter this
cable extra vignette comes directly from
crayon
it's awesome highly recommend checking
that out
then i'm also going to provide a
tutorial uh linked here in the area in
the document
for this formattable or format table
don't know how you pronounce that
package
so in this package you can really take
your formatting of tables to the next
level
i gotta be honest with this package i'm
not crazy about the syntax to it
and some of the features from this
package go so
far above and beyond it's a little bit
above what i personally need or want
from the tables i want to create from
day to day
but you may enjoy it so i'll provide the
link here in case you want to check that
out
now if you've seen my our markdown
tutorial you already know what the
difference is between a regular tibble
that you call
and a tibble that you pass through the
cable function
but i'm gonna remind you just in case i
start here by just creating this card
head table
that's just the first six rows of the
credit card data set
i stored in its own data frame i call
that
here's what that looks like but then
it looks very different if you pass this
through the cable function
now cable extra actually provides us
some tidy verse syntax for the cable
function
specifically we can use the pipe
operator here like we do with anything
else through the tidy verse
then we use this kbl function
this has the exact same effect as just
wrapping card head inside
the cable function but i personally much
prefer
using the using the pipe operator
so there's two very different
appearances here
now i think both of these don't
particularly look very great
but there's a lot of customizability
that we can do from here
there are various arguments that we can
pass to the cable function
and a couple of the most important ones
are align
and caption these are both fairly
self-explanatory
a line is going to help us align the
various columns whether that's to the
left
in the center or to the right and
caption is going to help us give a
give a title to the table so for a line
here i'm getting creative with it
i want to align the first seven columns
in the center and i want the next five
columns
aligned to the right so i do that by
repeating a c the c tells uh cable to
align in the center
repeating that seven times and then r is
repeated five times now you can tell a
little bit of a difference between these
two tables
neither of them look particularly great
here but these first seven columns
and everything inside the column so the
header and the contents
are aligned in the center for the first
seven columns
and then the next five columns are
aligned to the right
then we have this nice caption to the
table saying cable example with
uh with card data keep in mind though
these are just a couple of the arguments
that you can pass to the cable function
and so if you look at the help
documentation for a second
notice there's a lot of different
arguments to the cable function
so i highly recommend getting familiar
with this help documentation
just like every other important function
if you get familiar with this
documentation
it will really be your friend but you
notice from all these different
arguments
there is a ton of different
configuration that you can get for
tables
just from this one single function
however this is
just scratching the surface and a lot of
that configuration for tables that
you're going to be able to get
is through different cable extra
functionalities
and we're going to start with cable
styling that is
one of the key uh functions that you
want to know
out of cable extra so the bootstrap
options argument to cable styling takes
a few different
values the possible options include
basic
striped bordered hover condensed
responsive or none so let's get a feel
for what some of these different things
look like
so if we do bootstrap options equals
striped
just compare this table to this table
now what i did was i started with this
cable object which was created through
taking that card head table and then
using the cable function
aligning seven columns in the center
five columns to the right
and then giving it a caption that whole
thing just gets stored inside its own
base object here
but i want you to just compare this
table to this table
like even if the style of this table
isn't necessarily your cup of tea
you have to admit this looks a whole lot
better than this table up here does
so again all i did to do that was just
pipe
uh that cable object to the cable
styling functions
pass in the function or the argument
bootstrap options equals striped
this looks pretty decent now we could do
alternatively bootstrap options equal
bordered
and we've got a difference here notice
instead of these stripes going through
uh the rows here we have borders going
up and down each row and column
you could do bootstrap options equal
hover that way if we hover over the rows
here we get a
we get a hover effect you could do
bootstrap options equal condensed
this is going to make the table a little
bit skinnier you can do bootstrap
options equal responsive that's another
stylistic effect
but it's important to realize these
things are not mutually exclusive
so alternatively we can just put all
these things together
we can do striped bordered hover
condensed
and responsive and bam we have all these
effects
inside of one table notice we have this
hover effect that's
my personal favorite now there are tons
of different ways that we can customize
the look and feel of a table
other than just cable styling and these
options that you saw
so in particular if you're going to net
pdf documents
you do want to get familiar with using
latex options instead of bootstrap
options and it's going to be fairly
similar just with some different
uh options that latex options takes
instead of bootstrap options
but cable styling isn't even the only
function that we can pass to a cable
object
so there are other different style
functions we can use
those are cable classic cable classic 2
cable material cable material dark
cable minimal and cable paper so they
have key argument
light table options but you can pass the
same sorts of cable styling arguments
that you could
uh up here to any of these functions
so we're going to see some examples of
those along the way i'm just going to
radically change the look and feel of
these different tables
now the effect that i'm going for here
isn't necessarily for you to be able to
see
in every specific case what exactly
changed
but it's more to give you a feel for how
customizable these things are because as
you go along
you're not going to perfectly know
exactly what kind of table that you want
to create
right up front but knowing all the
different functionalities and arguments
that you can change
is going to be the most important thing
so again i'm going to change
uh the style function that we're using
along the way as well as the font and
font size
you can see an example here with cable
classic where i'm using light table
options equal basic
you have a lot more of an older classic
looking uh
feel to this table cable classic 2
is very similar notice here though
you have a different looking header on
top of these
column names here same with this kind of
border going on at the bottom here
you can use cable material here i'm
using light table
options equal basic but i'm also
configuring the font size and html font
to sans
this isn't necessarily my favorite but
maybe it is yours
similarly with cable material dark i'm
not necessarily a big fan of this dark
table with
white uh text sort of look and feel
but again that's something you can do
notice that i'm making the font size
smaller here as opposed to up here
there's cable minimal i'm using light
table options equal
striped and html font equals verdana
and then there's cable paper do light
table options equal striped and html
font equals helvetica
now again i'm showing you a whole lot of
different ways that you can customize a
table
and there's no one right or wrong way to
do this
you're going to have to play around with
this a little bit just just to get your
perfect sort of table
and what the perfect sort of table means
is going to depend on your personal
preferences
or possibly uh the specifications which
are given to you by your client
but of course the magic doesn't stop
there and if we want to customize
individual rows or columns we have the
option to do that too
so we've also got these two wonderful
functions column
spec standing for column specifications
obviously
and row spec now what i'm going to do
here is i'm going to take
columns 8 through 12 so if we count over
we go
8 9 10 11 12 here and i'm going to make
them bold
as you see we have regular font on the
left side but then columns 8 through 12.
we've made them bold now i also want to
take rows four through
six we go four five and six here
and make them italic now i'm also going
to make the background blue for them
and i'm gonna make the color of the font
gold and i'm gonna put these into
italics
so you've got that effect going on and
the effects are not mutually exclusive
as you can see with
uh these uh cells over here
notice that now we've got them both
we've got the font
both bold and italicized so
the possibilities here get pretty
endless then we can create
groups for our rows and columns as well
so we can start by using this awesome
pack rows function here now our
arguments are going to be
starting with the name of the group
let's just call group 1 for starters
and then the starting row and the end
row
for the group so i want to start at row
three
end at row five and i just want to make
that whole
grouping of rows green notice we've got
this nice
green title and border here that's green
similarly maybe i just want uh one
single row here in group two so
starting position is six and position is
also six
and let's make that red for group two
now if i want to create groups for my
columns that's easy enough to do i can
do that using the add header above
function
so the syntax here is pretty
straightforward
you just specify the names and then the
span for those groups
so for instance i want group one to span
four columns
i want group two to span two columns and
i want group three to span
six columns we look down here at the
table we've got
bam group one is four columns group two
is two columns and group three is six
columns now one last thing i'll say
about add header above
is that you can stack this so i could
pipe add header above to another add
header above
maybe if i wanted to put group one and
group two into like group
four up above then group three gets its
own group
five i know that doesn't necessarily
make a lot of sense in this particular
example
but that's something i can do so again
you can stack add header above if you so
choose to
lastly we can configure the font color
and the background of the columns
using the column spec function but the
way to do this
is a little bit tricky and
counter-intuitive
so how we're going to do this is let's
start with column
spec 5 we want to customize the font
color of this share
column here and we're going to do this
by mapping the colors
to the values so essentially
low values get a dark color and high
values get a brighter color
the way we do this is by configuring
starting and end points for the darkness
and for the brightness
so the spectrum here is gonna go from
zero to one
begin is going to default to zero and
end is going to default to one
i'm going to set end to point seven
which is going to tell this i don't want
the high values of share to get that
bright
so notice a low value here take this
.004
here it's got this dark purple color
whereas end equals 0.7
it's got we've got .067 here that's the
highest value
gets this greenish color here that's a
lot brighter but it's not
too much brighter however if we look at
what's going on with this expenditure
column here
notice in this case i just want the font
color to be a solid white
but i want to map the background color
to the values of the expenditure column
however i'm configuring this a little
bit differently this time
i want the beginning to be 0.3 and the
end color value to be at 0.8
so look at how this compares we take a
low value
9.85 and notice it's this purple color
but it's a little bit brighter than the
low values
of share in share look at the
font color for .004 here it's this
really dark purple
whereas this low value 9.85 gets this
slightly lighter purple now we have the
end equals 0.8
meaning we want the high values to have
a slightly brighter color than what we
had for share here
for share high value got this green
color for end equals 0.8 we're going to
get this
orangish color for the high value 546.
now i personally think for instance here
if you set end equals
equals one uh that this background color
would
get way too bright but again that's just
me you
your your opinion may vary now
taking this a step further you have this
option here which can take
uh values a b c or d and that's going to
change the entire color palette
so again you have a ton of different
configuration if you want to change the
the colors of font or backgrounds for
columns
that's all i'm going to show you today
for knitter and for cable extra
not because this is a completely
comprehensive tutorial of
everything that you can do with these
packages but i think for the
overwhelming majority of people
using these basic functions that i've
shown you and some of the key
arguments and the different options you
can pass to those arguments
you are going to be able to create a
table with the look and feel
that you're going to want again i can't
stress enough
just get used to the help documentation
and just play around with these
different functions
you're going to have to do a little bit
of trial and error to get things to look
just the way you want but with a little
bit of practice
knitter and cable extra functionality is
going to feel like second nature for you
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please consider
sharing it tap the like button and then
i'll see you all in the not so distant
future
until then richard on data